soutien des pouvoirs publics des
performances accrues investissements des
multinationales de nombreux voyants sont
au vert pour les énergies éolienne et
solaire
mais si les projets d'installation sont
de plus en plus nombreux et rencontre
bien souvent des oppositions de
riverains mais aussi d'associations
écologiques
alors pourquoi de tels projets ne
font-ils pas l'unanimité sont ils
toujours écologique
on y répondant facture certains projets
interroge quant à leur impact sur leur
site d'implantation
c'est notamment le cas d'un projet de
parc éolien sur la rive droite de
l'estuaire de la gironde un territoire
classé natura 2000 les marais de rive
droite de l'estuaire de la gironde situé
un espace ce tout à fait tout à fait
exceptionnel d'un point de vue des
enjeux de biodiversité
c'est un espace tout à fait remarquable
pour la faune la flore edf soit dressé
40 éoliennes à proximité de la centrale
nucléaire de blaye la zone semble idéal
car le vent y ait suffisamment fort et
régulier et que les habitations sont
éloignés avec à la clé une production
d'électricité pour 125 mille habitants
problème ce site d'une richesse
exceptionnelle s'avère déjà fragile sur
le territoire français entre 1960 et
2010 près de la moitié 50 % des surfaces
de route du mil aux disparus et
notamment sur la rive droite des marais
de gironde
on mesure sur l'essentiel du territoire
une dynamique érosive un recul du trait
de côte
à raison de un à deux mètres parle et
donc pas face à se baigner otages ont
bien que la conservation des zones
humides à l'avenir va passer en fait
parfois les hommes qui sont aujourd'hui
en zone rien toral zones où les
éoliennes devrait justement être
implanté ce qui pourrait porter
préjudice
implanter un parc éolien sur une zone
majeure de migration du littoral est
atlantique alors ça peut générer 2
faudra tout d'abord un risque de
collision
accrue aux différentes espèces l'autre
risque en fait ces paris ce que
d'évitement de la zone par les oiseaux
on a des risques de diminution de nombre
de migrateurs d'environ 25% et donc en
fait on va compromettre le déroulement
de la migration dans de bonnes
conditions
exemple avec la phragmite aquatique
alors c'est un tout petit oiseau qui
fait à peu près une dizaine de grammes
et qui pour descendre en fait en en sur
ces quartiers d'hivernage en afrique
subsaharienne va migrer par le littoral
manche atlantique et on a pu mettre en
évidence que les marais de gironde sur
cette partie rive droite de la gironde
constitue et d'escale extrêmement
importante à l'échelle mondiale pour cet
oiseau qui est aujourd'hui quasiment
menacées d'extinction
les projets sont aussi critiqués pour
leur gigantisme comme cette centrale
solaire voulue par angie et néo naine
située à saucats au bord des landes de
gascogne le terrain présente l'avantagé
d'être particulièrement plat et
relativement peu coûteux à la location
avec à la clé cette fois ci une
production d'électricité pour six cent
mille habitants
cette centrale solaire deviendrait la
plus grande de france ravissant la
première place à la centrale solaire de
cestas situé à moins de 15 km avec ses
mille hectares elle devrait donner
raison à jean marc jancovici expert en
énergie et membre du haut conseil pour
le climat en fait l'essentiel des
surfaces photovoltaïques qui sont
développés qui ont été développées en
france aujourd'hui sont des grandes
surfaces photovoltaïques donc l'énergie
solaire photovoltaïque en france comme
dans beaucoup d'autres pays c'est pas
une énergie de particulier c'est une
énergie d'industriels comme les autres
alors retenez que le photovoltaïque au
sol est à ses consommateurs des espaces
puisque vous avez besoin d'un hectare
par mégawatt de puissance et c'est un
hectare qui est mobilisé en quasi
totalité alors il ya des gens qui se
disent on peut en faire des ombrières
les mettre à trois mètres du sol faire
pousser des fraises en dessous etc mais
globalement c'est quand même un hectare
qui est mobilisé en quasi totalité
une autre manière de dire ça c'est que
sur un kilomètre carré c'est à dire 10
ha vous mettez 10 mégawatts de puissance
un kilomètre carré pour faire tout de
suite la comparaison qui vous
intéressent
c'est également l'emprise d'une centrale
nucléaire sur laquelle vous avez 4
gigawatts de puissance donc 10 mai
at 4 gigawatts 400 fois plus donc le
photovoltaïque au sol est très
consommateur des espaces le terrain
choisi occupe mille hectares de
parcelles d'exploitation forestière soit
l'équivalent du bois de vincennes
il faudrait donc coupée et des souches
et les pins pour installer les panneaux
solaires alors que ces arbres séquestre
du carbone un choix étonnant quand dans
le même temps on nettoie une ancienne
décharge à l'ouest de paris pour y
planter une forêt de la même taille qui
mettra 30 ans à pousser d'après une
étude de l'ademe
le département est un des mieux dotés en
termes de gisements potentiels des zones
délaissées et parking pour
l'implantation de centrales
photovoltaïques
dans le détail la gironde et les landes
représente 10,1 giga watt crête soit la
moitié de l'objectif national fixé pour
mais bien sûr privilégié des sols déjà
artificialisées s'avèrent plus coûteux
l'état français misent énormément sur
l'éolien et le solaire pour atteindre
ces objectifs climatiques
fortement soutenu ces sources d'énergie
font leur apparition dans de grands
groupes énergétiques comme edf nj total
et même des multinationales comme amazon
des projets pharaoniques voit le jour au
détriment parfois de l'environnement
lui-même il y a déjà un an
emmanuel macron l'admettait consensus
sur l'éolien est en train de nettement
s'affaiblir dans notre pays
avec de tels projets les énergies
renouvelables risque de perdre
l'assentiment de nombreux français